sophie dion monsieur le premier ministre
triste record pour le mois de février le
taux de chômage est en forte hausse la
plus forte depuis septembre 2013
et dans le même champ la quasi totalité
des pays européens ont fait fortement
baisser leur chômage la france est
devenue le seul pays d'europe où l'on a
peur d'embaucher la vision d'un code du
travail perçue comme une forêt être
obscur et hostile pour qu'on s'y
aventurent joue contre le recrutement de
salariés dans les petites et moyennes
entreprises
ces propos pourraient être ceux de tous
les chefs d'entreprise de ma
circonscription et pourtant ces propos
sont ceux des plus grands juristes de
gauche vous les aviez sollicités pour
faire du droit du travail un droit
contre le chômage et pour l'emploi le
premier projet de la loi travail
comportait des avancées significatives
pour redonner vie et souffle à ceux qui
créent l'emploi
la nouvelle version est un texte contre
le travail et contre l'emploi
vous aviez le choix entre écouter des
syndicats qui ne représentent
qu'eux-mêmes ou faire confiance à ceux
qui ont plus près du terrain connaissent
mieux que personne la vie et le monde de
l'entreprise
manifestement vous avez préféré
satisfaire à l'urgence politique plutôt
qu'à l'urgence économique votre texte
est aujourd'hui contestée de toutes
parts et de tous horizons même par votre
ancien ministre du travail françois
rebsamen
alors alors monsieur le premier ministre
peut-on savoir ce que vous comptez faire
de ce texte qui est devenue au fil des
semaines le symbole de tous les
renoncements et tous les espoirs déçus
merci la parole est à madame clotilde
valter secrétaire d'état chargé la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
t'inquiète pas j'aime ça modérez votre
admiration et on écoute la réponse allez
merci monsieur le président merci
mesdames et messieurs les députés je ne
m'attendais pas à un accueil aussi
enthousiaste et je vous en remercie
chaleureusement
c'est avec grand plaisir que je réponds
à cette question
et encore une fois je vous remercie je
m'attendais pas à cela c'est très gentil
voilà j'espère que vous n'êtes plus
intéressés par le vivons rue et par la
réponse que je vais apporter à votre
question que par le fait de manifester
votre enthousiasme je voudrais madame la
députée je voudrais madame la députée
vous vous faire reconnaître que le ton
que vous avez employé pour poser cette
question est pour le moins excessif et
que vous ne croyez pas une seconde à lui
mais ce que vous avez dit franchement
franchement nous expliquez nous
expliquer alors que les députés vont
être réunis bientôt en commission et
qu'ils ont déjà travaillé sur le texte
nous expliquer que le texte qui vous est
présentée par le gouvernement et qui a
été adopté en conseil des ministres n'a
rien à voir avec celui qui était qui a
été discuté avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales n'a rien à voir
et franchement et franchement se moquer
du monde
je pense vraiment que ça ne correspond
pas à la réalité il y a dans ce texte il
y a dans ce texte un certain nom des
logiques
il y a dans ses textes des logiques et
des veaux des objectifs que le
gouvernement recherche et qui sont
toujours dans ce texte quoi que vous en
disiez tout d'abord s'il vous plaît au
dialogue est au coeur des relations du
travail je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un objectif qui est maintenue
deuxièmement la protection le
renforcement des sécurités accordée aux
salariés à travers le cpa qui doit leur
permettre de rebondir
c'est également un point fort de ce
texte ainsi je pense vous avoir
convaincus
et nous reviendrons en commission sur ce
sujet et j'espère que vous aurez mieux
le déclin et merci la parole est à
monsieur dominique le